oder was geht ab hier soll max und heute
gibt es das erste gerät x max
was sie eigentlich schon gestern
beziehungsweise vorgestern machen wollte
und ich lege einfach mal los die hobby
jannik fragt wie hast du damals lud im
urlaub kennengelernt
ich habe lukas kennen gelernt das war ja
sommerurlaub und ich glaube habe einfach
im beach soccer turnier oder so
zusammengespielt und da haben wir uns
kennengelernt ja das gameplay im
hintergrund was ihr seht habe ich
übrigens chefs erspielt haben auch noch
entdeckt und ich bin stolz darauf weil
ich wollte ja gedauert mal ordentlich
spielen und da habe ich ganz viele
münzen gesammelt ich bin stolz auf mich
nächste frage
julia ludwig wie findest du die
derzeitige flüchtlingssituation und wie
findest du dass manche flüchtlinge das
essen wegwerfen
also in dieser bei satz dass manche
flüchtlinge das essen wegwerfen klingt
für mich irgendwie so nach bild -zeitung
irgendwie die flüchtlinge werfen unser
deutsches essen weg oder so mäßig ich
kann mir ehrlich gesagt nicht vorstellen
dass flüchtlinge grundsätzlich essen
wegwerfen das sind dann einzelfälle die
aber in den medien so dargestellt werden
als ob das alle machen würden ich glaube
nicht dass flüchtlinge die in
irgendwelchen zeltstädten leben und
jetzt gerade wenn der winter kommt mit
krassen problemen konfrontiert werden
dass sie einfach essen wegwerfen also da
soviel dazu ich glaube das ist einfach
sehr wahrscheinlich irgendwo gelesen und
da muss man auf jeden fall immer
hinterfragen weil sowas weil das ist
ziemlich häufig ein bisschen
ja so bild dir lass dir eine meinung
bilden mäßig ich weiß auch gar nicht ob
es aus der bild ist oder nicht also weiß
nur als beispiel weil ihr häufig auch
sehr eigene meinung vertreten
aber wie viel es die derzeitige
flüchtlingssituation schwierig also
offensichtlich wird deutschland damit
überfordert sein zumindest auf längere
zeit
deshalb finde ich muss man auf
europäischer basis eine lösung finden
und die verteilen einfach das dass man
das halt gemeinsam schafft in der eu
weil sonst ist das wirklich eine
schwierige situation aber ich habe das
natürlich auch keinen keine meister
antwort dafür was hältst du vom
hersteller babyphone gibt es ja viel
viel humor um das handy ich finde
eigentlich mein ist verkaufen zahllose
youtuber handy hüllen und nicht ein wort
man sich jetzt ein handy kauft wo es
schon darauf gedruckt ist und man pass
passions hat oder ob man sich eine
höhere machten sich die sachen
herunterlädt
da ist der unterschied ist auch nie so
riesig groß ich meinen zwar voll der
aufschrei durch twitter natürlich war
immer wenn da die oder baby irgendwie
sowas machen gibt's halt die contra aber
ich finde an sich das ist halt nur eine
neue form irgendwie das merchandise
meinen simon hatten aus werth gemacht
und so klein handys noch krasser teurer
aber ich finde es bringt nichts wenn man
das wie den weltuntergang erstellt die
meiner ansicht
da gibt es wahrscheinlich kleine mädchen
die sich darüber freuen und dann ist das
cool ich meine
früher haben sie halt leute geld für
barbie telefone ausgegeben jetzt sind es
baby telefon ja ja aber
nicht der weltuntergang aber gut ich
selbst feiere es natürlich nicht kannst
du mit just eine neue serie über
disstrack staaten wäre mega fährt
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr mit des tracks
mainz ii das wäre glaube ich ein
bisschen komisch wenn man so sagt hey
justin treffen wir uns am dienstag um
disstrack aufzunehmen keine ahnung ich
irgendwie ein bisschen strange weiß
nicht aber an sich macht spaß ich mache
es ja eigentlich auch öfters mal mit
justin und wenn wir auch mal lust drauf
haben machen wir das eigentlich immer
echt fragt wenn du von jetzt also nicht
mein bruder scott caan fahren wenn du
von jetzt auf gleich auswandern müsstest
du wohin würdest du und warum ist eine
schwierige frage
also es wäre glaube ich ziemlich
schwierig wenn ich jetzt aus wandeln
würde ohne abitur irgendwo so wirklich
fuß zu fassen
deshalb wäre wahrscheinlich ein land
sinnvoll wo es ein gutes soziales system
haben also irgendwie so irgendwie
norwegen schweden dänemark sonstwas
klöpse relativ gut aufgestellt
aber da kann ich dann natürlich nicht
die sprache das wäre auch dumm also ich
weiß nicht das ist echt eine schwierige
frage ich glaube man kann man kommen
kann sich eigentlich überall
durchschlagen mit ecken ich kann ganz
gut englisch sprechen aber ich weiß
nicht ein englischsprachiges land gehen
würde ich mir vielleicht sind nach
norwegen gehen und läuft meines wissens
auch relativ viel über englisch da bin
ich mir ganz sicher aber ich glaube so
was wirklich nicht
wie findest du die auszeit herbst
herr kuhl mag ich ganz gerne und kann
warme sachen fragen und ich finds
gemütlichem erster mann drin ist aber
draußen bist nicht so das allerschönste
dann denkst du wird es die erfindung aus
zurück in die zukunft geben diese slot
film heute schon gibt es war ja dieser
back to the future day aus dem film wo
die den was weitesten manhattan tut mir
leid wenn ich es nicht weiß hier einmal
vor ewigkeiten erst geschaut
sie erinnere mich circa gar nichts wenn
herr bergmann das sieht nicht schlagen
ist ganz lustig weil ich schreibe meine
seminare arbeit an der jagd arbeit
übernehmen das thema mein thema ist
grenzüberschreitung zwischen mensch und
maschine und ein unterpunkt ist die
realisierbarkeit von erfindung aus der
science fiction
also ich kann mir vorstellen dass ist
das bald vielleicht in 50 jahren harvard
gibt ja prototypen fliegende autos gibt
es ja auch prototypen dürfen also es ist
alles erfunden und technisch möglich
aber halt nicht so leicht wie das im
film dargestellt wird aber ich glaube
ein bisschen zeit kommt es schon alles
so der o kein doppel elli fragt warum
benutzt du eigentlich keine interviews
mehr
gute frage ich finde irgendwie zurzeit
bekannten finde ich so meint werner für
mich so ein bisschen zu farbenfroh und
mein intro finde ich ein bisschen
langweilig und deshalb bin ich im moment
designtechnisch beziehungsweise
eigentlich generell mich so ein bisschen
neu aufstellen was content angeht und so
weiter die videos sind ja mittlerweile
auch ein bisschen anders als die noch
vor drei monaten sage ich mal waren wo
ich halt vor allem pvp hochgeladen habe
macht ja jetzt auch aber das ist halt
anders ich weiß nicht versteht dass
bestimmt wie ich es meine
und ja keine ahnung finde ich nicht mehr
so cool also wenn ich die sachen sehe
dann denke ich mir so ok ja
kennst du halt schon ewig mach mal was
neues also ich habe auf jeden fall ja
ich arbeite zurzeit an einigen dingen
die ganz cool werden könnten so er tue
was erst im deutschen bereich so viel
musik außer cosmo gang und dem bau also
kosten geld gerne hier sagt money boy
höre ich fand mich meine ich höre mir
selten lieder von moneyball öfters
anhalt außer wenn er irgendwie sowas
drop wie jetzt burke war nicht voll cool
und manche sachen höre ich mir halt
vorläufig aber grundsätzlich das nicht
so unendlich häufig deutsch ist ganz so
leicht bei mir
deutsche musik höre ich eigentlich wie
gesagt sehr wenig
weil ich finde das irgendwie deutsche
musik kann ich schnell nicht ernst
nehmen so und so dieses ganze deutsche
pop schon gar nicht so marc forster
sowas habe ich eine krasse aversion
hingegeben
also es richtig schlimm ich das im radio
höre dann muss direkt das radio
ausgeschaltet werden so kann ich gar
nichts ab ansonsten gibt es ein paar
sachen die mir mal gefallen sind so wie
du bist und so was kann man sich auch
mal geben es ist auch nicht mein
lieblingslied aber er hat auch schon ein
paar coole stellen aber wie gesagt ich
kann sehr schnell passiert das dann dass
ich denke so okay für mich halt krass
sowie bei deutschen rappern und so keine
ahnung weil irgendwie auf ich weiß nicht
ob es eine sache der authenzität ist
oder ob man nicht so 100 prozent
dahinter steigt wenn es auf englisch ist
aber ja so ist das
wie findest du shipping videos von deren
blut und bist du jetzt echt vergeben
oder ist es stecken montreal shipping
videos von mir und ludwig spitze nein
das mega lustig und grundsätzlich finde
ich immer cool ein zuschauer irgendwas
starkes machen und ich bin tatsächlich
vergeben abermals bleibt trotzdem noch
real freunde ja ich liebe dich lieb mich
zusammen
ich würde das was man jetzt zehn fragen
circa neun minuten ich weiß nicht keine
ahnung ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
wie sie uns mal nicht mal wieder macht
es gut und bis zum nächsten mal